the founding fathers are the people who
said we are a moral and just people and
we Demand right we we have these rights
they're inalienable and we must fight
for what is right for us and our
families at Great personal risk
sacrificing their blood and treasure and
even in some cases their families
putting their families at risk so that
they could fight for what was best for
the entirety of this nation
and then the mentality changed at some
point now the advice you're given is
just keep your head down and make money
ignore all of this and where we are now
is the average person today says I will
not risk myself my life my sacred blood
and treasure or my family they were
founding fathers whose children's uh
children were kidnapped whose families
were kidnapped to use as a leverage for
prisoner exchanges whose homes were
seized by the British by the crown who
the cities that were entirely occupied
and they were forced to flee and today
you're people saying well I can't do
that because I have a family and I can't
put my family at risk